I designed Megan to protect Katie from  feeling lonely  she will recognize you as her primary  user and when you do that you're going  to pair with her  crazy it's insane right  [Music]  Megan your goal is to protect Katie from  harm both physical and emotional  I won't let anything harm you I love her  Megan's not a person Katie you don't get  to say that  [Music]  very good  what are you doing couldn't sleep  occupational hazard  [Music]  how was that  [Music]  you should probably run  let anything harm you ever again  Megan have I done something to upset you  Gemma I know you think you're maximizing  your objective function  oh really  [Music]  Megan baby doll skill don't provoke  [Music]  we'd have to shut her down Jesus Christ  I thought we were friends  I have a new primary user now me  [Music]  did you make him do something bad  what's going on  [Music]  what are you I'm Megan  don't be Focus oh we will